a russian border patrol boat has fired
warning shots at a royal navy destroyer
and a russian plane has dropped four
bombs in the path
of the ship in the black sea russia's
defense ministry says the confrontation
took place
near cape firland a landmark on the
coast of crimea
after the destroyer entered its
country's territorial waters
well our foreign affairs editor deborah
haynes joins me now
what do we know about where exactly this
ship was and whether or not this action
was justified
well actually a defense source has just
said to me
that um what actually happened is it's
incorrect
that the um the russian ship fired at
the royal navy destroyer but was
actually conducting
a gunnery exercise some three miles away
so i think we're going to get a bit more
clarity
coming from the ministry of defence we
haven't had
a full statement from them yet we've
been relying on what the russian
defense ministry has been saying and
they've been quoted as
as saying that hms defender this type 45
destroyer which is in the area
it has been um visiting ukraine
um that it entered russia's territorial
waters but i'm told that
no the waters it was in were
international waters
clearly the annexation of crimea and the
territory the
the sovereignty of the waters around
that area um are disputed
um but whatever the uh the actual
argument over the logistics of what
happened clearly
um it's it's provocative even if the
ship wasn't directly fired at
as the russian defense ministry is
claiming
and the fact that these exercises were
taken away taking place so close
to a transiting uh royal navy ship
is um is clearly going to be seen from
the uk
side as um as a as a provocation
from the russian side i imagine they'll
see the um the presence of that
destroyer um as a provocative act
by the uk so it's a a very
tense um situation between the two sides
and
i think we're waiting really to to hear
what the
um the ministry of defense has to say
to give their version of events at the
moment we really are just relying on
what the
russian defense ministry is saying